À laquelle du vote populaire
ne risque-t-elle pas de vous conduire sur les
terrains de l'extrême droite,
sur certains sujets de société,
comme par exemple l'immigration.
Mais il n'y a pas de sujet tabou,
il n'y a pas de débat tabou.
Et je pense que on a 1 problème à gauche,
c'est que pendant trop longtemps,
il y a certains sujets qu'on n'a pas voulu traiter.
Mais moi je le dis,
la question euh de l'immigration,
la question euh.
De La Défense des intérêts français et la question
aussi de l'insécurité,
c'est des sujets que nous traitons avec 1 discours
progressiste, que nous devons porter.
Bien, moi, je le prends à bras le corps.
On a besoin aujourd'hui à gauche
de ne pas nous adresser que
à celles et ceux qui habitent dans les centres
des grandes métropoles.
On a besoin d'aller rechercher ses ouvriers,
ses travailleurs qui
se sont sentis méprisés
euh. Par euh, par la gauche parfois,
pour leur dire et leur montrer que y a 1 gauche
qui n'a jamais tergiversée sur euh,
la question européenne,
qui a toujours contesté cette construction européenne,
euh, libéral, euh, qui euh
aujourd'hui se présente à l'élection européenne
et surtout, je pense que la gauche
c'est trop divisé sur les débats de société.
Et bien moi, aujourd'hui,
je suis à la tête d'un rassemblement de la gauche
qui souhaite faire de la question sociale,
de la question du pouvoir d'achat et du travail
ses priorités.
Et je pense que chacun à gauche
Devrait faire en faire de même